most of the characters in the movie are
given choices to make and they make the
choices that they make and they pay the
price so the consequences or they live
to tell the tale because of those
choices and we actually see it happen
all three different times in the movie
if you just look at the case of John
Travolta and Sam Jackson it would
suggest well okay Sam Jackson made the
good choice made the right choice and
thus he prospers and John Travolta pays
no attention to it and thus we know he
dies but you have to think about Bruce
Willis's choice that happens in this
movie because he actually makes two
choices one he makes it a choice to do a
very unhonorable thing you know he
actually makes the deal with Marcellus
Wallace to throw the fight he doesn't
have to Marcellus doesn't say throw the
fighter you're dead he makes it for
money and he takes the money and he
screws Marcellus with it but he actually
ends up living to tell the tale right
because he actually does make a moral
choice later when it goes back to save
Marcella so the whole movie isn't about
Redemption but Redemption does keep
working itself in to the movie